Baroness Hale who for years was the only
female judge in the Supreme Court has a
long history of self-identifying
publicly as a feminist now she's
repeated views her experiences as a
woman and a mother inform the
perspective that leads her to her often
brilliant judgments having women on the
court she says improves the quality of
decision-making there's so much evidence
that diversity does improve
decision-making not because one gender
or race is better than another but
because a mix of perspectives creates
more sophisticated thinking the only
difference between Hale and her male
colleagues is that they don't admit how
their gender affects their perspective
while she is transparent about how being
female affects hers if you need a
reminder of why unchecked testosterone
is bad for at institutions just look at
the allegations all of which are denied
against US Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh we need both more women and
more feminists in courts which among
other things have the power to make huge
decisions about women's bodies Hale is
paving the way and that should make us
proud
[Music]
therefore you and I have talked with
each other and I understand you have
legal training
what is your legal training what's my
legal training yeah I used to be a
barrister right you used to be a
barrister you have at least said that
Brett Cavanaugh denies all the charges
you'll be aware the allegations which he
denies were done when he was at high
school before he even became a judge so
what does that got to do with it why do
I think it's relevant that he he was
allegedly he was allegedly aged between
15 and 23 because it's because and it's
important to say that the judicial
appointment yes it's very different
because she is facing hearings but she
denies element of his character and his
career if you put yourself forward for
the highest office in the land
Constitution you destroy did you hold
yourself out to a higher level of
scrutiny decide it is guilty no of
course not that's why I'm having a
hearing your argument which had some
validity to it although I don't know
necessarily because issue said you're
man you're not gonna make a person
you've absolutely destroyed your
argument by impugning the no matter
I'm computing if anything why are you
making the link wouldn't bring a charge
it's nothing to do with it I keep you'll
find the reason that we're seeing the
women who are accusing him giving
evidence before the Senate committee is
because it is seen as highly relevant to
his judicial point he was a high school
I know he was a high school but he has
he watched his nomination hearing I've
held himself out in a very specific way
as a paragon of virtue Family Values
if you hold yourself out as one thing
and there's evidence that you've behaved
in a different way I think that deserves
to be scrutinized not by my presence
improve the sophistication of pledged
thinking next rally a little bit and I'm
actually gonna do something I never for
whatever do on the back you up started
okay right I do when I was a kid right
and I do respect that women should be
given the same opportunity within the
legal system and I'll tell you why when
I was a kid I was about what 15 years
older than the children's own and I got
done for a little fight downtown and I
like to go in front of the beak all
right so gets hauled in all right gets
charged I get sent back to the
Children's Zone and then I'm looking
forward to going to court right and all
the other kids go
or if you get that woman you were in for
it boy you're gonna get some do not mean
if you've got the female he was in
trouble he was in big trouble jumping
cuz the female she was evil she was
gonna do a big time I mean she was
hatred filled of it so I think females
in the legal system I was going to say
the opposite I was going to say that
actually if more women were involved in
conflict resolution things wouldn't lead
to violence as they so often do
especially when we've men declare war on
each other and patchy I mean I think
women have the same right as everyone
else to be violent and aggressive and
the point is have a range of
perspectives and they're sometimes
different I'd like to make the point
which is I think you were wrong to
distinguish women men and feminists I
think a lot of men are feminist and not
necessarily that you know and there are
some very feminist men in in the legal
profession having said that I think
Baroness Hales point is right there are
many more pale stale male people in the
legal profession than Hale get it see
what I do there are no senior male
judges as far as I'm aware who have
publicly self-identified as feminists oh
come on
police we don't want to assume that any
of them are feminists if they've never
said it the party like job is really
some incidents that the only person who
said there are feminists can we have a
stat on women's actual penetration into
the legal profession on screen please
which is that the women make up 55% of
Magistrate's 29% of court judges not bad
forty percent of 46 percent of tribunal
judges and twenty only twenty four
judges in the court of appeal and
obviously there are any couple in the
Supreme Court so I've got a question for
Nick Oh
Nick how would you like it if just get
rid of all the men and just simply have
all female courts I don't know be
helpful to talk what I am agreeing that
women resolution very good empathetic
judgements we take everything it just as
it shouldn't all be male and it
shouldn't all be white and it shouldn't
all be female and it shouldn't all be
mixed right so show me that I'm gonna
I'm gonna disappoint you wouldn't it be
even better if if all courts looked a
bit more like this and who's in the dock
with the judge can't imagine which and
who's who's the bodyguard
with windy if you listen to be pledges
perhaps you listen to Ann Widdecombe
writing in the Radio Times and I want to
put this to you raft with an Rachel Ann
Widdecombe says and I quote women have
never had it so good we have a woman
Prime Minister again and a woman in
charge of the Met Police
we have women chief executives women
judges women running media here a woman
there a woman everywhere a bleep bleeped
it's the age of the wine and the winds
of the moan and the grown women have
just as much a rights everyone else to
be bigoted debated here because you're
not saying that you don't think women
should be known you're saying you've
seen the same thing what's the dispute I
mean I'm saying that I think we need to
recognize that it is important to have
women not just at the junior level which
we saw those better representation but
at the senior level I mean there are no
people of ethnic minority heritage in
the Supreme Court at all there's one
Court of Appeal you intend to do it well
it's interesting when you look at the
actual demographics of the legal
profession where judges come from
because now there is a lot more
diversity so the question is why are
they why women why people for minority
backgrounds not progressing it's a
senior-level
addictive discrimination and quotas
others in the sometimes treating
everyone the same does not result in
equal treatment yeah no sir Rachel's
question I mean I'd say focus and
opportunity as opposed to outcome
because Dave the danger there of course
is it can lead to it can lead to
unqualified people of the danger because
we've been seeing for the last few
hundred years interventions in favor of
white men in the judiciary that's why
they have been if you put in a judicial
point that was literally a tap on the
shoulder from the Lord Chancellor
right oh that's still that's who I
imagine to be charitable to what you've
just said you're saying that there's an
unconscious bias at play which needs to
be addressed which I agree with I'm not
so sure
quotas of the best way to address are
either but I'm saying that the status
quo
has not been sacked and we've been
putting up with it for to be and I
really welcome seeing someone at senior
level are now saying that we need to be
a bit more radical in thinking about the
consequences of not having society
reflected in the judiciary because it
does make a difference
as Phil said had he not had that women
in court he might have gone down jury
and I think I'll rule a mistrial you're
watching the pledge on Sky News coming
up I promise that I will do my best to
be true to myself and develop my beliefs
to be fearless and controversial and
keep the pledge
[Music]